and I want to say this this might be
controversial but I feel like I am an in
cell that I broke out free Wow the hue
made it I'm gonna tell you this I'm laid
though no not always
yeah what happened was when I was in
high school I realized during Sadie's
Hawkins hmm that's a winter formal
no that's when the girl asked the guys
out when the girl eyes asked it's the
best I never went
you were never asked stop that was the
best I enjoyed it
never went and of course you enjoyed it
you know why you Bubba got asked early
on physically people open up you're a
son of a [ __ ] oh are you mr. varsity
blues mr. giant [ __ ] I went to the day
of muscles and shoulders away anyway
some of us come on Bobby didn't get
asked some of us got funny no don't
please don't finish my [ __ ] my rose
all right my cousin Andy my fat cousin
Andy and I used to take my core Eliza
Brown Corolla like I'm station wagon oh
yeah we put out the edge of the cliff
and we'd sit on the hood overlooking
Sadie Hawkins where the school was power
high school yeah on a cliff and I used
to talk to Andy about either killing
ourselves we're killing everybody in
there right you know just just as a talk
yeah you're right
and then you graduate from high school
and you realize oh I'm never gonna get
[ __ ] mm-hmm yeah because I now not only
am I have I have that in sell packaging
right now I have no I don't have the
sparse smarts so I can't develop an app
to make money we all get good grades in
high school college or you get paid
playing video games yeah right
- now I'm in trouble yes right so at 23
I walked by the Comedy Store in La Jolla
because I was walking to work because
that there was a coffee shop that never
but you're always funny that were just
cracking your friend I don't know okay
no I was scared like that we'll probably
on some databases yeah I mean yeah my
name was on some lists okay and as I
walk by and it had a Help Wanted sign
and I thought to myself I have to either
try or become nothing
mmm and I tried I knocked on the door I
got a job I did the Open Mic I became a
regular now it moved up and now look
right so I'm an in cell that like you
know got out of his predicament yeah but
we've always had in cells you know so
that that's a very there's not the Joker
they're looking for a nice that's a
legit I hope people hear that because
it's like that's form of desperation
where you go I have one shot to get out
of this or I'm gonna be nothing
yeah but in cells have to realize it's
in their mind mmm if you're an in cell
and you're like in a you know you know
one-bedroom apartment somewhere Jack and
Eve jerking off you know keep in the
valley or whatever and you're thinking a
[ __ ] like this and just know right that
we've all been there yes
you know and some women baby something
burn every once a while
dolma bone that wrong that's it bad no
do you have to cut that out I don't have
to bad is that a bad point of view no
I'm not in cells a bone so they they
don't say it's not with the woman's
responsibility so you know what don't do
anything women and [ __ ] you in cells
Jesus dude you just turn them whole
culture guy I know I know sometimes you
guys have to cut me up I don't know what
a politic no no no I was talking you
guys were like no but I like that story
doesn't say nothing you're like keep
going you don't know what you're talking
about going but I have pretty shirt down
but I appreciate that story and I won't
sorry it's what half sure it's not the
same I well it's not the seventies but
you believed so then whatever I did the
comedy store everything
and then one day Jennifer field came up
to me this white woman hmm
and she was 23 and she's like hey I live
in Oceanside and other with my mom you
know it's a sign
you should come over tomorrow um I went
over there but she saw me perform and I
did 69 with her in our moms Claudia Lee
yeah that's what so oh can I never had
did not only was she white
[ __ ] you young and hot that's when I
remember Jesus Christ yes no I remember
being in the clock I put your PIN oh no
I'm doing the scene now all right yeah I
was in the closet right okay I remember
doing the class
neither clap with the class in the
closet it you know and I'm doing it you
know whatever was you ask guy to Brian
what I'm doing this don't go yeah yeah
yeah no I'm right there and going and I
remember looking up at the heavens right
going the brown heaven yep yeah I think
look the Lord Jesus your vagina taste
like Heineken yeah yeah then did you
that's what happens lost in a hot blood
that's from that's from a book called
the brief and one's life of Oscar Wow
first time he goes out on a girl ski he
goes she tasted like Heineken
inna by Junot Diaz is when we get to
serious Brian I went through him busting
though is that the game anyone like yeah
and she was how did that
did she just start how did that happen
like 69 is now is a bold first move its
aggressive we didn't start I didn't go
from walking into the front door and 69
there's a built like a thing man that's
good right so cuz I didn't she cuz I
thought maybe she was like can you clean
the pool yeah because I had never had a
girl come up to me and go I want to heal
with you in a sexual way so when they
said when they said let's hang out I
wished I was a job I don't have to move
something or you know man
it's none of us so when I when I went to
her house we had dinner and they came
back around either closet though wasn't
their bed thing not I think because she
had animals like a lot
get in the hut get in the closet but let
me say something I [ __ ] her maybe 20
times that summer yeah yeah and I mean I
literally would cry yeah it's the
greatest lover oh you were 23 also being
a fat asian guy yeah Korean dude doing
the time in the late mid-1995 you know
all these Ali Wong's and all these other
like Jimmy delicious things and all you
should be thanking you
they should be blowing me but um and you
open the doors trimmed I nod to judo
Mizzou the Jackie Robinson of Asia did I
not one of greats right Robinson one of
the greats I'm one of the greats am I
not yep you got a dude you got a place
shirt down man
shell I wonder what that girl's doing
now
you're thinking about that no I don't
want to I don't want to wash it look
like I don't know what did she look like
back then she was blond beautiful eyes
maybe be nice fat being to these though
big kitties yeah very big but beautiful
face Princess Diana died though that's
how I know that's how I opened the
conversation Diana died yeah yeah Diana
died so that will how far what year was
that when Diana died 1994 I'd say three
I'm gonna say 94 it would have to be
after 95 because that's when I started
doing stand-up so 95 is when I started
and I know that she had died in d7 so
yeah so that's why that happened so when
97 I was working the door at the La
Jolla Comedy Store that date which is
probably a Saturday I don't know but I
did an eye open for a joke Oy and he had
some old-school
the guy was Asian said he opened he
worked with you at the time there was a
door guy bigger dude
okay he's Asian does he location yes
kind of could be Mexicans he said he was
a jolly wait so just rewind what he just
said that all right sometimes confusing
you know I said is the agent you go
kinda but could be Mexican I'm saying
he's for sure Asian but if you didn't
know for sure he my bike is that a big
Mexican so if I was blind
I could go maybe he's a Mexican that's
right yeah you could yeah
hey what are you saying you're saying
it's right it's right yeah that's what
it is yeah why would you guys working
with each other you've been running out
lately
no what do you mean it's low energy no
because he starts thinking about his own
career during his own nepotism and I
make it about him he's like I don't even
have a tailor tomorrow what he's doing
Hewett tomorrow
Bobby's got this he's got a good funny
point of view into tomorrow and then I
got a call a see about yeah the Wardrobe
thing and then my hair thing do you know
what nepotism means they say nepotism
yeah who knows what a nepotism and
whatnot but doesn't mean I think no
that's what I wanted to say narcissism
you know I know what nepeta nepotism is
what will says Will Smith is doing with
his son yes that's what it is yes it's
where you promote those you're related
to position Authority where they don't
man I mean we got a couple more colonel
baskem let's do a cup I'm gonna say this
though you got bit laughs out of this
thing yeah we did yeah I mean my knee
hurts you do not get good laughs out of
all asses right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue oh good what's gonna
happen what are you gonna do use some of
that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]